evening what's the matter are you afraid
the vampires have no need to worry
I'm not staying for dinner I'm here to
guide you through a brief history of
vampires illustrating how our image has
changed from shambling corpse to the
dapper gentleman you see before you
vampires are nearly as old as you humans
stories about us revenants appear in
cultures extending as far back as
prehistoric times
but we weren't cold vampires back then
and most of us did not look the way we
imagined vampires today far from it for
example the Mesopotamian lamashtu was a
creature with the head of a lion and the
body of a donkey at the ancient Greek
strigas but simply described as
bloodthirsty Birds others were even
stranger the Philippine manananggal
would sever her upper torso and sprout
huge bat-like wings to fly the Malaysian
Penang gallon was a flying female head
with dangling entrails at the Australian
Yemaya who was a little red guy with a
big head a large mouth and blood suckers
on his hands and feet oh and let's not
forget the Caribbeans suku Yount in the
West African over evil and the Mexican
trill hell pooch arming aren't they
though they may look vastly different
all of these beings have one common
characteristic they sustain themselves
by consuming the life force of a living
creature this share the trait is what
defines a vampire all the other
attributes change with the times
so how do we arrive at the reanimated
fellow you see before you
our modern ideal emerges in 18th century
eastern you
with a dramatic increase of vampire
superstitions stories of blood sucking
shadowy creatures become nightly bedside
terrors and popular folklore like tin
mulu among the Romani people and Baloo
got in Albania provide the most common
vampire traits known today such as
vampires being undead and nocturnal and
shape-shifting do you see Eastern Europe
in the 18th century was a pretty grim
place with many deaths occurring from
unknown diseases and plagues without
medical explanations people searched for
supernatural causes and the found what
looked like evidence in the corpses of
the victims when villagers dug up bodies
to discern the cause of the mysterious
deaths they would often find the
cadavers looking very much alive longer
hair and fingernails bloated bellies and
blood at the corners of mouths Hey
clearly these people were not really
dead Hey they were vampires and they had
been leaving their graves
to feast on the living the terrified
villagers would quickly enact a ritual
to kill the undead the practices varied
across the region but usually included
beheadings burnings and staking the body
to the coffin to prevent it from getting
up grisly stuff but what the villagers
interpreted as unholy reanimation
they're actually normal symptoms of
death when a body decomposes the skin
dehydrates causing the hair and
fingernails to extend bacteria in the
stomach creates gases that fill the
belly which force out blood and matter
through the mouth unfortunately this
science was not yet known so the
villagers kept digging in fact he hits
so many bodies were dug
that the Empress of Austria sent her
physician around to disprove the vampire
stories and she even established a law
prohibiting grave tampering still even
after the vampire hunts had died down
the stories at Legends survived in local
superstition in this led to works of
literature such as Polydorus
the vampire the gothic novel Carmilla
and most famously Bram Stoker's Dracula
although Stoker incorporated historical
material like Elizabeth battery's virgin
blood baths and brutal executions of
Vlad Dracula it was these local myths
that inspired the main elements of his
story the Transylvanian setting using
garlic to defend oneself and this taking
of the heart while these attributes are
certainly familiar to us elements he
invented himself have also lasted over
the years fear of crucifixes weakness in
sunlight and the vampires inability to
see their reflection by inventing new
traits Stoker perfectly enacted the
age-old tradition of elaborating upon
and expanding the myth of vampires as we
saw we met my relatives a huge variety
of creatures stalked the night before
Dracula Hey and the many more will
continue to burn it through our
nightmares yet so long as they subsist
off of a living beings lifeforce they
are part of my tribe even sparkling
vampires can be included after all it's
the continued storytelling and
reimagining of the vampire legend that
allows us to truly live for us
you